a mission to mars it's been a hope and
ambition a dream for many space programs
around the world but we expect to hear
very soon
from the united arab emirates that its
probe known as hope has reached the
orbit
of the red planet well it would make the
uae the fifth country to reach
mars orbit after the u.s the soviet
union europe and india so it must be a
very exciting time
for the woman heading the effort well
that is her excellency sarah al-amiri
and i'm very pleased to say she joins me
now not quite from mars but from dubai
sarah very good morning
to you what's the very latest please
good morning ian uh but currently the
team is
observing the spacecraft the spacecraft
looks very good exactly where we want it
to be to start its operation to get into
orbit around mars
we're a few hours away from this orbit
from this sequence starting
we will turn on our thrusters for the
longest time we've ever turned it on
this is a purpose-built mission and
therefore we will go into orbit
by burning half of the fuel and that
will take about 27 minutes of
of using our thrusters as our braking
system to
significantly reduce our speed from
about 121 000 kilometers an hour
relative to mars all the way down to 18
000 kilometers an hour and we start
entering orbit
um at an altitude of about 2 300
kilometers from the surface of mars
that all is the 27 minutes where we have
absolutely no control over the
spacecraft
and we hope to come on the other side of
this on orbit around
mars being the fifth nation that gets to
mars and hopefully starting our
scientific mission
it is very exciting isn't it i mean
fewer than half of the spacecraft ever
sent to mars have made it i mean have
you ever had any doubts in your mind
that you could achieve this
so this has been a severely rehearsed
and tested
to the brink of our capabilities to test
see
the sequence uh we are comfortable with
the level
of operation of the spacecraft we've
been operating it for about six months
now
well over six months actually we're
comfortable with our understanding of
how the spacecraft responds
to space um and it's with this that we
enter
into this final phase and probably the
most difficult phase of this mission uh
prior to
starting the science of the mission but
as comfortable as you can get at the end
of the day
the odds are the odds 50 of these
missions are able to get into orbit
this is the first time that we use this
system and we're just
we're just looking forward to um being
at the other
side of of this anticipation uh it's
been a true challenge but it's been a
true learning experience for
the 200 engineers researchers and
practitioners who have been part of this
mission
and what is the kind of data that you
plan to collect
so we're going to be uh the first
weather weather satellite of mars
therefore capturing characterizing the
weather system of mars through an entire
year different from other missions who
have covered it during different
times of the day we're going to
comprehensively cover all times of the
day across
all of mars and that will allow us to
also understand what roles
what role martin's weather system plays
in atmospheric loss so say if there's a
dust storm on mars and the storms of
mars usually
cover the entire planet uh how much
impact does
do those dust storms have on loss of
hydrogen oxygen therefore
client loss of the atmosphere these are
some of the studies that we're looking
into investigating with this mission
and crucially though you won't be
landing on mars itself which uh
nasa are sending up their rover called
perseverance right now that
that's actually going on to the planet
surface why aren't you doing that
so our science requires us to map the
whole planet's weather system and it's
best to do that
while you're in orbit around mars and we
do fly at quite a unique orbit
around the planets it's a highly
elliptical one at our closest point
where
twenty thousand kilometers from the
surface of mars at the furthest point
for forty three thousand kilometers mars
usually your science questions and
objectives drive
these missions if you would like to
comprehensively cover the planet then
orbiting is the way to do that
if you want to to study a particular
area of interest then using a rover or a
lander is the way to go
and crucially you will be making all the
data that you collect publicly available
to anyone who wants to see it from
september this year absolutely
this data needs to be available to all
scientists around the world our science
team doesn't get a hold of this data
prior to
any scientists working on any other
tangential area of research
and this has been fundamental and
foundational in our design of this
mission
now one of your objectives with this
mission also was to get more students in
the uae more interested in the stem
subjects science and maths and so forth
have you succeeded in that absolutely
just today as we are speaking right now
all schools within the emirates both
private and public schools
are taking a lesson on mars we are
seeing more and more students excited
today morning my daughter pulled up a
space book and explained to me
how we can send humans to space and and
how
rockets are built so this is
infiltrating every single household
everyone is very excited about this
and it's given us a common understanding
on the importance of science
not only from the perspective of
everybody needing to study science
diversity is always important in terms
of fields but from the perspective
of ensuring that there is an
understanding of science and
an appreciation of the role that it
plays in society
now assuming you're successful with this
mission what would the next
objectives be for the emirates space
programme
the space program has always been about
diversifying the economy and
establishing sectors
especially industries that are deeply
rooted in technology
our next step is to take a lot of this
knowledge that has been acquired over an
experience that has been acquired over
the course of the last 15 years
and start spinning out companies uh that
are able to tap into the private sector
of space
especially with a lower access to um to
space
and what would you say to people who
might say well hang on there's an awful
lot of problems down here on planet
earth right now
most of the planets in the grip of a
horrible uh pandemic shouldn't we be
focusing resources on
sorting that out before we start looking
at uh exploring other planets
so there's multiple ways of us driving
science forward
and as we've learned from the pandemic
ensuring that you have a solid base for
science in every single area even
not at a time of crisis allows you to
help for
utilizing science at the time of crises
any science based amongst
any nation needs to be diverse in nature
you need to enter
into various fields because the beauty
of scientific discovery is you don't
know
where you're going to use it until it's
utilized and if we continue thinking
down the line of
we still have problems on earth then we
wouldn't have for example mri
machines which were driven by the space
industry and by the space sector and by
exploration of outer space
and that today is a vital part of
diagnosis uh for
for all of humanity within hospitals
science does not have an
application sciences about discovery and
exploration
and after that is when the application
comes once we have an understanding of
of the unknown that we're trying to
discover okay and uh just to reiterate
uh sarah
there is still a lot that could go wrong
at this late stage isn't there
yes this is if i take the last six years
of deve
of development all the way up to launch
and all the way through cruise
all the challenges that has or that has
that we've encountered throughout the
last
uh six years equals to the 27 minutes
that we're
going to witness today to enter into
orbit around mars
we completely understand these
challenges we've designed these missions
to circumvent these challenges
i think everyone is aware today
especially in the emirates on
what it means to get towards mars and
what we can possibly face and there's
various scenarios uh
that we we might face uh getting into
orbit around mars
well very very uh nerve-wracking time
for you do appreciate you joining me
this morning best of luck with it all